Uh,
in,
in my forthcoming book,
I have a section where I talk about professors who got into Trelawney.
We've all heard about the comedians getting into trouble for violating some
politically correct dictum,
but professors,
many cases,
very,
very high profile professors getting in trouble for incredibly innocuous jokes.
And actually I brought a list of names cause I thought I might not remember
them.
Can I mention a few?
The few of the cases.
So Lasar Greenfield who was the president elect of the American College of
surgeons and the Editor in chief of a journal called surgery news.
W had written an editorial a few years ago where he was talking about the
antidepressant benefits of coming in contact with sperm and other words,
it,
and this was based on a peer reviewed scientific paper.
Actually two of the authors of that paper are folks that I know quite well,
friends of mine.
And they had demonstrated that women who have protected sex versus unprotected
sex and up scoring differently on these depressive measures.
In other words,
there was some sort of protective element to actually being exposed to sperm.
And so in his,
um,
editorial,
he made a joke.
It was during Valentines,
he said,
so now there is a gift that a man can give a woman that's beyond flowers or
chocolates or something to that effect.
He had to step down from being president of the American College of surgeons.
He had to step down from being editor in chief because a whole bunch of women
were very offended by that sperm joke.
Now the,
the,
the authors of the paper and question wrote a brilliant response.
The response where they said,
how,
how could he be treated in this way when all he was doing is actually literally
reporting the data,
the findings from our peer reviewed study.
So that's one example.
Another example is a certain,
uh,
I think his third Tim hunt,
who was a Nobel Prize winner in 2001.
I remember this one.
Yeah,
right?
Uh,
who,
who he basically,
he was a speaking,
I think had in Korea at a,
you know,
gee women in science conference where he varied in a jocular way,
said,
you know,
it's a real problem when you have women in your lab.
They fall in love with you,
you fall in love with them.
And so it's better to have segregated labs.
His wife,
by the way,
as a staunch feminist,
who's a very prominent scientist,
and she confirmed that he's hardly,
you know,
a rabid sexist.
He went through all sorts of hell.
Yeah,
I remember that.
And he was joking and he was joking.
And I,
in the book I discussed several other other of these examples.
So,
so imagine you would think that a unblemished exemplary career as a scientist up
to getting a Nobel prize,
good,
potentially protect you,
but one comment that someone decides can,
can unleashed a tsunami of outrage and you're dead.